[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE WILLIAMS: Doctor
Edwards Deming said,
if you can't describe work as a
process, you can't improve it.
One of the most powerful and
accessible process improvement
tools we have to learn with is
something called a process map.
A process map is a visual display of
the activities of a process or a system.
Process maps are extremely
useful and helpful
for understanding how
a current process is
designed by enabling you to quickly
identify opportunities for improvement.
Once a process has been
improved, process maps
can also act as guidance to
support people doing standard work
and following a designed
process reliably.
Process mapping is a powerful
exercise for learning and improving.
I often describe it as one of the
secret weapons for helping teams
to identify variation and potential
failure points in their work processes.
In an ideal scenario, I
like to do process mapping
with a mixed group of stakeholders of
the process we're trying to improve.
I also strive to go to where work
happens versus doing it in a conference
room or a meeting space.
I begin by inviting the team to
think about the average patient
or someone who represents the
normal population this process must
serve every day.
Then I ask them to attempt to describe
the process at a macro level, as
high a level as possible.
So let's take an example here
and draw just a simple diagram.
So usually, every process has a start.
And the start and the end often
use a shape that looks like a pill.
And then what you do is
you start to ask yourself,
what are each of the
steps in the process?
And so we might go and say,
well, here is step one.
Put a box there.
And step two.
And step three.
And maybe after step
three, there's actually
a decision that has to be made.
So we reflect that by
making it a diamond,
and that may bring us to an
extra process step down here.
So if yes, for example, it may continue
on-- I'll put a little Y here, or just
write a yes-- it'll continue
on down the process.
If it's no, then there
might be a decision
to go down here and fix something
before the process continues.
And then we keep going until we
reach the end, and again, at the end,
we often describe it as a pill.
So each step along the way, right.
We've got process step
one and two and three
and then there was a decision that
had to be made, and so that either
takes us to step four or drops
us down here to this step
before we move up to four.
But it's basically a
simple visual display
of the steps in a process
from start to finish.
Now, in my experience,
most teams won't make it
past the first step or the
second step in a process
before they start describing
multiple ways a step can be done,
or they disagree on what the step
is or identify a failure point.
All of this is fantastic for
generating improvement ideas.
This dialogue and listening
here is essential for learning,
and I try to balance
keeping people focused
on getting to a first draft process and
honoring and capturing all of the input
from team members.
There are a number of
different approaches
you can take in doing a process map.
From the very basic
hand-drawn flow diagram
on a whiteboard or piece of paper like
I just did, to more complex variations,
including value stream analysis,
spaghetti diagrams, swim lane diagrams.
Each helps us understand better
how work actually happens.
Process mapping is a great tool.
Think about a process you want
to better understand and see
if you can map it out
from start to finish.